quand j'étais jeune j'adorais les films
10 ni la musique les histoires des
chansons mais le film qui m'a le plus
marqué c'est à la dengue de vous
rappeler si l'histoire d'un jeune paysan
pauvre qui trouve une langue magique et
quand il fera de cette lan est un génie
qui a paraît il a le génie hors cac la
dengue trois souhaits en réfléchissant à
ses choix à la demande au génie ce que
le génie souhaiterait avoir s'il avait
trois choix le génie surpris par cette
question parce que personne ne l'y avait
jugement ne lui avait jamais demandé si
qui souhaiteraient avoir sa liberté
parce que le génie était prisonnier de
la langue chaque fois que quelqu'un soit
à la lampe cette personne devenait son
maître et je raconte cette histoire pas
parce que nous avons des longues magique
coup de génie de notre société mais
plutôt parce qu'aujourd'hui dans le
style riche et moderne
nous avons encore des personnes qui ont
beaucoup plus de liberté que d'autres
j'ai eu la azor de naître dans une
famille aisée
mes parents on travaille très fort pour
offrir à moi et à mes deux frères des
opportunités on a fréquenté les écoles
privées on avait un chalet ont voyagé et
à l'âge de 26 ans
j'ai pu me lancer en affaires pas parce
que mes parents me l'ont financé mais
parce que je n'avais pas de dette
étudiante et je savais que si j'échoue
et mes parents seraient là pour m'aider
à me relever mon ambition n'est pas la
norme
quand je grandissais au chalet hésiter
il y avait une auberge à côté d'un homme
qui était gérée par deux retraités il
avait un petit enfant que s'appeler
martin martin est un joueur brillant
joyeux intelligent et nous sommes
devenus de très bons amis mais à penser
grands parents il n'avait pas beaucoup
de soutien la maison son père était plus
ou moins là et sa mère étaient sur le
bien-être social
les corps en o2 situation s'est
manifestée par l'âge de 13 ans
j'habitais un moyen les marques y
habitaient la rive sud
je l'aï invité à venir me rejoindre la
fin de semaine à montréal et il me dit
qu'ils n'avaient pas assez d'argent pour
prendre le temps
bus et que sa mère n'avait pas assez
d'argent pour l'aider à prendre
l'autobus pour venir me voir
le fait que le prix d'un billet
d'autobus puis séparés mon ami de moi
m'a choqué et m'a marqué comment peut-on
à avoir tant d'écart de richesse dans
une société comme la nôtre
je pense que nous savons que la solution
à nos problèmes de société n'est
rarement simple mais depuis plus de 200
ans des personnes des philosophes des
économistes proposent une idée qui à
première vue m'a semblé franchement fun
ça s'appelle un revenu de base c'est
inversement universel et inconditionnel
ça veut dire que vous moi martin tout le
monde recevraient inversement dans leurs
comptes bancaires
à chaque mois au québec il ya plus de
2600 programme qui offre un soutien
financier aux citoyens aux entreprises
franchement il faut avoir un doctorat en
bureaucratie pour naviguer système est
trop souvent ce sont les personnes
aisées avec les comptables et les
avocats qui en tire bénéfice
comment une mère monoparentale peut-elle
s'en sortir il ya mille et une raisons
pourquoi revenus base est une bonne idée
mais je vais m'en tenir à mes trois
préférés en premier un revenu de base
nous permettrait de simplifier le
système de automatic
l'idée est de remplacer notre filet de
sécurité qui est extrêmement complexe et
coûteux et qui laissent beaucoup quatre
personnes passent à travers avec une
fondation stable sous les pieds de tout
le monde qui va permettre à chacun de
passeurs son avenir je me demande des
fois comment la vie de martin auraient
été différentes si lui et sa mère
avaient un revenu de base à l'époque
potter qui n'auraient pas décroché de
l'école secondaire comme de nombreuses
études démontrent
je ne sais pas exactement comment sa vie
aurait été différente mais je sais qu'en
rhume base l'horaire au moins aider à
maximiser ses chances dans la vie car ça
aidera niveler le terrain de jeu
compétitif de notre société
les scientifiques et les chercheurs
expliquent souvent que pour faire
avancer la science
leur but n'est pas de trouver des
solutions complètes à les problèmes mais
plutôt de trouver la solution simple
après avoir trouvé les solutions
complexes
nous avons trouvé la solution complexe à
nos problèmes de société si l'état
providence ça fonctionne relativement
bien notre société aujourd'hui est
infiniment mieux que la société de nos
grands parents mais je pense que vous
serez d'accord pour dire que si on veut
faire avancer la société
au 20e siècle il faut penser autrement
ma deuxième motivation pour un revenu de
base et la suppression de nos programmes
paternaliste qui stigmatise et divise la
société
tantôt j'ai fait mention du fait que la
mère de martin était sur le bien-être
social en préparant ce discours
plusieurs personnes m'ont dit m'ont
suggéré de plutôt dire qu'il était à
faible revenu parce que le bien être
social n'est pas bien vu le bien social
et beaucoup d'eau près à multi ville
sacrée deux classes de citoyens sacré
des contribuables qui travaille fort et
qui payent leurs impôts et des personnes
qui tirent bénéfice du système également
les personnes qui pourraient bénéficier
de ces six de ces programmes que nous
allons mis en place ne le font pas par
peur par crainte ou par ondes ce qui
souvent va mener à des situations encore
pire et plus difficiles à corriger en
revenus bas âge nous permettrait de
mettre tous les maux de la société dans
la même classe de personnes des citoyens
ma troisième motivation points revenu de
base est la plus simple c'est que nous
avons le droit de vivre dans la dignité
il faut voir leurs revenus base comme le
droit de vote
un droit fondamental à la base notre
société en offrant un revenu de base
on va offrir la dignité à tous et nous
savons que l'humanité de chacun d'entre
nous dépend de l'humanité de tous nous
n'aurons jamais de société parfaite mais
je crois qu'il faut surtout viser une
société où chacun à une juste chance
dans la vie vous soyez riche et que vous
soyez né dans une famille riche une
famille pauvre
vous devriez ont les mêmes opportunités
il est clair pour moi comme martin il
n'avait pas les mêmes opportunités
la critique la plus fréquente du revenu
balle c'est que les gens arrêteront
travailler
mais les projets pilotes effectuent au
canada et ailleurs démontre que ce n'est
pas le cas l'argent qu'on verse aux
individus est utilisé surtout pour
investir dans leur avenir est dans
l'avenir de leurs proches que ça soit
conduit leur éducation et des noms de la
famille où l'ancien projet une
entreprise qui les passionne le revenu
base est un outil essentiel pour libérer
les personnes de leurs contraintes socio
économique
je veux surtout que la vie des enfants
de martin chômeurs et que ses enfants a
eu des opportunités
il ya encore beaucoup trop de personnes
dans une société qu'ils n'atteignent pas
leur plein potentiel et la dépendance le
crime le déchet décrochage scolaire
coûte très très cher ça coûte très cher
non seulement aux personnes qui sont
dans ces situations mais à leurs
familles leurs proches et à la société
en général un revenu base nous permettra
d'éviter beaucoup de ces problèmes avant
qu'ils se produisent on peut également
comparer à un revenu de base à
l'assurance maladie
quand nous avons instauré l'assurance
maladie dans les années 60 il y avait
beaucoup beaucoup de positions des
médecins et d'autres personnes disaient
que si vous n'avez pas l'argent pour
faire traiter par un médecin c'était de
votre foi ou s'il faut des tombées
malades vous êtes blessé de ne pas avoir
économisé suffisamment d'argent mais
après de nombreuses années de lutte et
de leurs débats nous avons déterminé que
non l'accès au traitement médical est un
droit fondamental et quand l'offrant à
tous on allait s'enrichir parce qu'on
enlève cette crainte de faillite
financière liée à une blessure ou une
maladie je suis un radicalistes et j'en
suis fier parce que leur vie base est
une idée radicale qui arriva à la racine
de nos problèmes et offre un remède
en conclusion je vous demande de ne pas
penser à ce que votre voisin ou votre
ami ferait avec 800 $ de plus par mois
dans ses poches
d'ailleurs la suisse voté par référendum
lors dans la couronne nationale l'an
prochain point un revenu base de 3000 $
par mois alors lui sont dehors c'est pas
grand chose
alors nous demande de ne pas demander à
ce que vos voisins votre ami frère 800
dollars par mois mais plutôt à ce que
vous ferez et je suis convaincu que vous
voulez investir et dans votre avenir que
vous aiderez vos proches vos enfants
votre famille potable aux parents le
revenu base est une des qui doit être
mis en place au xxème siècle si on
souhaite faire avancer la société
au 10ème siècle nous avons lutté
ensemble mettre en place le droit de
vote
au 20ème siècle delon mis en place
l'état providence au 20e siècle
je suis convaincu que c'est le temps
pour rohff d'une base à la fin du film
aladin quant à eux d'un étui son
troisième et dernier souhait pour
libérer le génie le génie ne peuvent pas
et plus content je crois
fondamentalement qu'il n'y a aucun
émotions ou sentiment plus puissant que
l'émancipation et la liberté
je vous demande de m'aider à libérer le
potentiel de tous nos concitoyens et de
nos enfants merci